hey everyone this is steve weintraub
with collider and i am here with the
people behind for all mankind i have
repeatedly said again and again this is
one of the best shows on any channel i
love this show so much i can't i know
how hard it is to make any piece of art
in hollywood and i just want to thank
you for the long hours and everything
that goes on behind the scenes to bring
this to life and a huge thank you to
apple tv for
this is going to be airing after
comic-con weekend so a huge thank you to
apple tv also for the fourth season i'm
just gonna say um i'm very very happy um
and on that note you're done i just
wanted to sing your praises and say see
ya um but listen one of the things that
i love learning about um and i think
fans like to learn about are things that
they wouldn't know about the making of a
show and what goes on behind the scenes
i've asked you this ronald
ron but not everybody else um what do
you think might surprise people to learn
about the actual making of for all
mankind and i need you to grab a mic the
sets are all practical we are actually
in space
that's the first thing that you need to
recognize sure absolutely uh apple does
have money and they have they have
one of the richest companies in the
world and uh the sets do indicate that
that is true
i i think that what would shock people
the most is how small those spaceships
are especially the first and second
season space capsules of the apollo era
they are so small they're disturbingly
claustrophobic and i feel bad when
there's cast that has to like get inside
these things especially in space suits
it's like they're just very cramped and
they're based on the real deal so it's
like you you go in there and you realize
there were actual astronauts in these
things for like a couple of weeks and
it's insane i would say it might also
surprise people how hard it is to age up
this very young looking cast we spend so
much time and trying to figure out
prosthetics and that are natural looking
but i mean we have such a young looking
cast that it's shockingly uh time
consuming i'm sure in the chair once
they also have to do it it's also tough
but um you know we are aging 10 years
each jump so it's um it's a constant
work in progress well one of the things
about the third season the third season
is my favorite thus far and it's just
the writing is just so good every
episode is like a finale for for the
cast can you sort of talk about reading
these scripts because they are fully
fleshed characters really great
storylines um i'm just curious what it's
like reading these things and knowing
you're gonna be inhabiting these
characters
i mean i i remember reading
my favorite thing to do is to read the
first episode back each season because
you wonder where your character's gonna
be in
the world now ten years later and for
karen it's always somewhere very very
unexpected um like space the place that
she effin hates the most so
um and and i love that but you're right
the same reaction you have to each
episode we have in our group chat where
we're like oh my god you're doing what
holy sh i'm doing this like we we feel
the same way and so it's awesome to see
that it translates once we actually
finish shooting it and editing it and it
goes out to you guys that um it's as
shocking for us and we have the same
reactions that we get to be president or
we get to own a space hotel or um be
blind or whatever that it might be uh
that kind of comes our way and i think
we kind of champion for each other's
characters as well yeah we also all uh
any fan will know this already but we
also on our own island not all of us but
their storylines are very disparate in
some ways so we may know a little bit
because our creators don't love to share
many details even with us but we all
know a little bit about our own arcs and
our own journeys but we know nothing
about one another's so to me one of the
best parts about reading scripts and
having table reads and then of course
seeing the show once it's made is
getting to see what everyone else is up
to so it's just as thrilling to me
anyway to see what eddie's doing and
what sonia's doing yeah and one of the
most attractive things for me on the
show is the uh the room that the writers
give the actors to perform and be it's
very
grounded so when you're reading the
scripts just imagining everything that's
on the page being delivered in a
grounded way that's not network rushed
uh the performance is
just truly saying i really wanted to
join the show because of all the
performances that everybody was doing i
mean the thing that uh i feel like is
one of my favorite things is the there's
like a ping pong match in my head when i
have read a script and then when i see
the edit when i see the finished episode
that's one of my favorite moments is
seeing like what was actually on the
page what
was made on the day and then how was it
edited together i love seeing kind of
that journey so i always find that
really exciting and yeah just seeing
what you all do in your scenes because
you're right we are kind of siloed a bit
and then we kind of merge and
go away so yeah it's really it's really
cool to even like go back like you said
and read the scripts and be like wow
that's how that was manifested it's
really beautiful ron's heard me ask this
before i'm going to ask the cast uh
obviously in season three there is a
starship i mean it's getting you to mars
but it's not like the star trek starship
and i'm just curious what season do you
think it'll be when for all mankind gets
the actual like starship
he's asking the cast
on that note um this is maybe a little
bit also of an answer to one of your
earlier questions seeing the number of
of ships that the production design team
designs and like the full journey of
like what that looks like and then what
actually is on screen i also think is
incredibly interesting and it's
something that you would never imagine
there's so many iterations and and
season four is when we're on the
starship right
margo's driving finally
but i'm being actually serious like if
this show stays on the air for long
enough we are eventually going to get to
a trek type starship so ron let's talk
about it is it season six is it season
seven it's it's out there you know it's
something we talk about i mean it's part
of the plan of the show is to eventually
do you know how do they reach for the
stars and when does that happen and and
uh
we have a plan for it i'll leave it at
that
for the actors another thing that must
be really rewarding is that you know the
show is every 10 years and you're
actually if depending on the character
there is um you're basically going to
watch someone's entire life as the show
goes depending on i don't know how
season three ends i haven't seen the
last two episodes but i would imagine
there'll be some transition or but i
mean what is it like for actors playing
people
you know
on such a journey
uh i think
for molly it's a unique one in that
molly's uh essentially the same person
throughout she is this curmudgeonly
badass from beginning to end who loses
her sight but doesn't
doesn't go through in many ways the kind
of transitions that i think so many of
the rest of the cast go through these
huge
seismic journeys molly's focus from a
little girl was to go to the moon that
was
what she wanted to do and to work for
nasa and that is what she got to do and
even blind is still working at nasa
until she gets fired
anyway
uh
fired
so so so that you know in a way was a
really lovely thing to play aging to
play maturity to play weariness to play
blind
but um this woman has such integrity
throughout uh i found that
really lovely a very a very reassuring
thing to come back to every year i
didn't have to worry about what molly
thought of the 80s fashion or how
molly's haircut had changed or what
music molly was now listening to
molly
the mold doesn't change it's the same
human all the way through so that was i
think
maybe different from how many of the
others uh approach their roles
i mean i i that was my favorite thing
was the challenge of the space in
between each season and then once i
found out you know where karen was going
to be what she was doing what was
happening filling in all those gaps
sitting down and choosing
who did i vote for what music did i
listen to um and because she does change
so much between
each season and in those ten years and
i loved that uh i guess challenge of
going and looking at history what was
happening or fashion or whatever that
might be but also the personal journey
of let's say going through grief and so
much loss between season one and in
season two how do we find her there and
then the same between two and three
which is a much more giant leap into a
different space um and it was really
exciting to to learn about this woman
and also still familiar
you know when you come back to it
because it's still
karen it's just a new evolutionary
version of it and i think that's
hopefully what the audience feels as
well and why they love each character
ron i'm so curious you are what we call
i'm gonna use the term busy i think busy
is a is an accurate term with you um how
much do you i know you love this show
how much do you get to actually like
work on it like can you sort of talk
about you know how you are able to
divide up all your time with all the
different things you're working on well
you know the plan was always to to hand
the show off to matt and ben who i
co-created the show with and so they've
really you know taken the reins and been
the the on the deck show runners for a
while now but you know they keep me in
the loop i get to read the scripts and i
get to look at the cuts and you know if
if they have questions or a problem or
you know a notion that they want to uh
run by me they pick up the phone and we
talk about it i love the show i get you
know i like to look at the dailies you
know even though i don't really have a
need to look at the dailies you know
it's that kind of it's that kind of
relationship again i don't know what's
gonna happen at the end of season three
so i'm gonna be careful as i say this
but um what can you guys tease about
season four which starts shooting in
like a month or something not much i
mean you know we have a plan
there's a time jump
it moves forward
a lot of things change at the end of
this season that uh you know
platform the show into its fourth season
um i don't even really know how to talk
about it because it's you know the
scripts are underway uh we have a plan
we know what we're doing in the fourth
season but
you know we just kind of want viewers to
come in and be surprised so you know we
we tend not to spoil too much more
wrinkles
more wrinkles
more wrinkles more wrinkles one of the
things i love about the show is the
opening montage of episode one of each
season well uh season two and you know
what i mean uh the opening montage and
i'm so curious because i know how much
time they spend with the editors putting
this thing together figuring out what's
gonna be there i watched the season
three opening montage now like three
four times for you guys what is it like
watching that and and when they finally
put it together because it's really
really so well done and so well edited
yeah
i i always watch it cool sorry i always
watch it and wish we'd had it as a
teaser for us to sort of put us in the
right space before we started shooting i
always feel like oh that would have been
a great trailer to have had playing in
my trailer kind of thing and give you
the juice of just to get you like in the
era it's such a beautifully beautifully
crafted thing and like you said it is so
much work for our post-production team
it literally tortures them
almost around the clock until that thing
is done because there's so many layers
to to those montages from music to legal
clearances to clips to visual effects
it's just it's so hard and they do an
amazing amazing job on that
to sonia's
point though i think i can't remember if
this has happened every single season
season two and season three obviously
not season one but we do at least i have
in the past gotten like a bullet point
list of what those pieces are so we are
sort of shepherded into the cultural
reality of the time and what's happened
that isn't our real history and what of
our real history didn't happen and we're
sort of brought up to speed that way but
i know what's on you're saying like
there's such a visual emotional
component to those montages that um make
it sing obviously but just yeah we do
know what's up they'd these guys keep us
informed i have to wrap it i just want
to ask real fast for the actors um
i would imagine that sometimes your
character does things you completely
disagree with like 100
what is it like as an actor playing
somebody who is making a decision that
you're like what the you know like
you're completely against is it fun to
do that or is it you know can you talk
about that
everyone side-eyes me i'm not even gonna
talk about that moment um i'm gonna talk
about the first moment when um i think
season one episode three when i'm fuming
because this one here is gonna go to
space with my husband and that's not
what women are supposed to do and i'm
saying these words that i
fervently do not believe in my real life
like the feminist in me is so angry that
i have to say these things and i had to
recognize the place that it was coming
from for kieran which was fear uh
insecurity which is something we can all
relate to as humans and then speak to it
from something that i actually you know
maybe believe that much in my own life
and forget that the words were something
that made my blood boil but um i do love
that i do love that there's different
opinions because if you didn't have
somebody like karen
then you know you don't have somebody
who's stuck in the mud and you don't
maybe see the change in progress as much
i think there's this lovely moment that
we caught in the elevator and the third
episode of season three that i think
might not have been as juicy had i not
felt so uncomfortable because it's just
so palpably there it's
it's when margot and sergey's fingers
start to intertwine and it just you know
i was so excited to see how it played
because i feel like margot just looks so
deliciously uncomfortable
um so i i don't know i think sometimes
that actually that that disconnect or
that uh uncomfortable uncomfortable
feeling actually can feed
a scene in a really interesting way
sounds totally and i mean we're all
actors because we don't want to be
ourselves for brief moments of the day i
think so there's something in that but
also you know like i'll never forget the
moment where ben and matt you know i'd
known i was going to be the president
of seasons ago but i did not know i was
going to be a republican and that was
certainly interesting
feminist queer republican president who
has to claim she's pro-life that was a
fun day for me personally very contrary
to all the things i care most about i
listen i gotta rap with you guys i could
ask you a million other things i just
want to say one more time um i love this
show if you're not watching you really
need to watch i want to thank every
executive at apple tv for putting this
thing on the air for all of you guys for
the hard work thank you so much